hi everyone welcome to this episode of
the into the impossible podcast i'm your
fearful host
dr brian keating doing a continuing
series of pandemic podcasts today we
have a phenomenal guest and that is avi
loeb who's a legend
in our community is the author of
literally 700
research referee journal articles uh
several textbooks
a new textbook on the way i think he was
writing it as i'm doing the interview
with him
he's so productive but his book today
that we're discussing is a popular
science book that you're going to love
called extraterrestrial and it's about
this
rather startling claim that uh he
believes that
the discovery in 2017 of an
object traversing our solar system at an
extremely high
velocity much higher than even the
saturn v rocket achieved on its way to
the moon
leads creedence to a claim that he makes
and fleshes out in this book
that there's only one conceivable
explanation for this object
it was a piece of advanced technology
created
by a distant alien civilization so
certainly
uh it's a controversial claim but it
also really illuminated and exposed a
dark deep secret of the scientific
underbelly in avi's opinion
when he had colleagues and even former
students etc
they turned their back on him they
shunned him and i think it's
really kind of a glimpse into the
psychology of science
herd-ism and other phenomena that you
find in
science where authorities can either be
accepted without question or they can be
targets
of approbation and maybe even a desire
to take them down a peg
uh to get uh to get them back or to
somehow
uh benefit from their uh from their
accomplishments so we talked about a lot
of things we uh we talked about the
full theory of how he believes this
object was sent
from a distant solar system what it
means why
he thinks it's very likely that it is uh
alien technology not just a piece of
space schmutz he we also talk a lot
about the
uh the nature of science itself and risk
taking
and how little risk taking and how much
up
not obfuscation in the sense of making
up data but lack of transparency maybe
is a better world a word uh and now how
that intentionally in his opinion is
is do is being undertaken by our fellow
scientists to
maybe protect and and confuse uh the
public and
even funding agencies to advance certain
agendas you're going to hear his
vehemently anti-you know kind of
extraordinary extraordinary claims about
theories of everything such as we've
been exploring on this podcast
and i think it's uh it's refreshing to
get this view we don't agree on
everything i pushed on him in a couple
of situations
but it was a really fascinating
conversation i know you're gonna love
i ask you to do me one favor and one
favor only
i don't have advertisers uh yet on this
podcast
so i'm asking you to pay me back so i
don't have to necessarily go there
then maybe i would if the if the right
uh
the right opportunity approached itself
but um but for now i like to have it
nice and clean
and only ask you to do one thing and
that's to
leave a rating review and subscribe and
forward the podcast to other people
avi is really a fascinating person i
want people to hear about his
controversial ideas
so please do that subscribe leave a
rating on itunes
subscribe on youtube and on itunes or
wherever you get podcasts
i hope you enjoyed this episode of an
out of this world
episode of the into the impossible
podcast enjoy
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
anyway today we are speaking with
none other than professor avi loeb who
is a uh a legend in his own time
and he may be a legend even
intergalactically we're gonna find out
about that uh
he's the most uh productive i think he's
writing a paper as we speak he's the
author
of 700 papers i've read i've read about
665 of those i'm working on the
remainder
by the end of the week i should be done
but today we're talking about his book
a phenomenal book called
extraterrestrial avi how are you doing
today
thank you i'm doing very well actually i
should say that over the past
nine months uh it has been the most
productive period in my life because i
was
at home under house arrest so to speak
thanks to the pandemic and
uh didn't have to commute to work and
most importantly didn't have to listen
to uh remarks from colleagues that make
no sense and so i could just work on
on my research and and write the
papers and and essays and um
it was a very productive time every
morning i i jog out
i go to the woods and surrounded by
ducks birds and rabbits and
it's it has been a very enriching period
of time for me
yeah i've been trying to get i've had on
uh ray weiss
on the podcast in the last month i've
had on barry parish and i'm trying to
get the troika
uh including kip thorne and he keeps
agreeing to come on the podcast on the
into the impossible podcast
but he says that he can't resist how
productive he's been the last few months
and he has to keep postponing our
conversation ever
ever longer so uh and one of the
characters in in the book we'll talk
about obviously
uh it was no stranger to uh to science
popularization and
and getting stuff done including during
very difficult times
and of course i'm speaking about my hero
and i suspect yours too galileo galilei
the first observational astronomer he
plays a big role in extraterrestrial
before we get there avi i want to ask
you how did you come up with the title
how'd you come up with the cover design
and uh and
what is it like to write a mass hit like
this is sure to be
uh when it comes to be your role not out
not inside the the
traditional role of a harvard astronomy
professor but as a popularizer and
communicator of science so first of all
the name of the book the subtitle and
the cover design where did it come from
yes so i should say titles and labels
are
the list of my concerns so i have a lot
of
leadership titles you know i'm the
director of two centers at harvard the
chair of
national committees and so forth that's
not really what i care about
you know i i'm driven mostly by
curiosity and
just as i was when when i was a child
you know trying to understand the world
that's pretty much
from a point of view of being modest you
know that's pretty much what i'm i'm
about
and the same is true about the book uh
the title the subtitle
and the cover were selected by
the publisher the editor and the my
literary agent
uh i am really you know mostly
responsible for the content
and therefore i would highly recommend
not to pay attention or significance to
the cover judge the book by not by its
cover
but by by what it has inside us the
saying goes yeah
so i usually ignore that advice and
always judge the book by the cover but
you're absolutely in good company
because this book uh is called the
dialogue
concerning the two chief world systems
uh written by your late colleague or the
forward written to it by stephen j
gould of course at harvard but uh and uh
they forward to the original edition
1913 written by some guy named
albert einstein i have all these voodoo
dolls here um
and i'll be showing them i i had one
made up of you too avi uh you
get to see that at the very end if you
cooperate but no
worried about it uh just teasing that
that point but galileo do you know what
the original title for this book was
uh avi no it was on the flux
and reflux of the tides in oceans
and ferns i don't know what a fern is i
kind of looked it up but
he was forced by essentially the index
of uh the catholic church's inquisition
to change it to a much more appropriate
and interesting title in my opinion the
dialogue
concerning the two chief world systems
and i've actually seen
an original copy of this a a colleague
of ours
uh professor jay pasikov at williams
college he donated a copy
to the williams college library he was
of course the student of donzel menzel
at harvard whose position you have
basically right
or as as chair uh so it's it's quite
it's quite delicious to talk to you
uh and and recollect these things about
great scientists including galileo
you make the point in the book not
directly comparing yourself to galileo
of course that would be immodest
and uh and so forth but you do compare
the reaction
by colleagues who should know better and
should have the committee
to trust somebody like it's not like
you're a crackpot i get emails
every day i'm sure you do too professor
loeb uh einstein was wrong
uh i can i can show you how he's wrong
but i'm not good at math
so if uh if you help me i'll split the
nobel prize with you and i actually
talked to uh
harvard alum adam reese and he said yeah
how do you think i won the nobel prize
but um but what do you make of this
sometimes you know people attack for
for obvious reasons actually galileo was
wrong about the tides as you know
uh that was an incorrect piece of
evidence what do you make about people
that
have a bit of knowledge and and really
just kind of disregarding
you and your claims in this book that
we've been visited by
not only intelligence but technology
from an alien civilization
right so the example i i like to bring
up is
a book that was written about einstein's
theory of relativity
uh in the 1930s arguing
that it's wrong and there were you know
several
tens of people signed on the book and
when einstein was asked about it he said
why do you need so many people
it's sufficient to have one kid make the
argument
and explain why i'm wrong i don't need
the crowd of people
you know so a crowd gives people the
authority
you know and that was true in the days
of galileo that
the philosophers the church you know
they were the crowd and he was a single
individual
trying to argue something that was not
popular at the time
and he said look through my telescope
look at the evidence
and the the earth actually i think moves
around the sun and they said
we don't want to look through a
telescope we know the truth and they put
him in house arrest
and of course the point of the matter is
that it did change the fact that the
earth continues to move around the sun
it just maintained their ignorance so we
can
bury our head in the sand we can put
blinders
and not look at reality but the fact
that we ignore reality doesn't change
reality
reality stays the same the duty of a
scientist is to find out what the world
is
not to close uh or put blinders on our
view
not not to avoid looking through
telescopes not to dismiss
anomalies when they are found and the
you know it's a lesson from history and
it's very unfortunate in the current
culture of science
this is not the guiding principle
instead you know so you might say okay
maybe the scientific community is very
conservative
and to that i would argue great because
believing that if you reproduce the
conditions on earth on billions of
planets you know we now know that half
of the stars like the sun have a planet
of the size of the earth at a similar
distance
from its star and therefore liquid water
may exist on its surface in the
chemistry of life as we know it
and you roll the dice billions of times
what's the chance that we are the only
ones you know very small
so the conservative view would be to say
that if you reproduce the conditions on
earth you get the same
outcome let's go and search for it that
is
supposed to be the mainstream view and
instead it's a fringe view
and the mainstream says don't ever talk
about
the alien technologies don't even speak
about the possibility that
you know we might be common uh out there
um because you know we don't want to
talk about it there is a taboo
and anyone that talks about it
immediately gets dismissed
or ridiculed and you know frankly i
don't care how many likes i have on
twitter
because as i said before if you ignore
reality it doesn't matter
you know and the duty of me as a
scientist is to behave just like a kid
you know i don't care about what my
colleagues say and you know
try to understand and by the way making
mistakes is part of
being a scientist you know if you look
at einstein at the end of his
career in the 1930s he made three
mistakes he argued that black holes
don't exist
gravitational waves don't exist and that
quantum mechanics doesn't have
action um you know at a distance spooky
action at the distance
he was wrong on all three counts but
that's part of being at the cutting edge
of science
so my point is uh
we should uh as basketball coaches say
we should keep our eyes on the ball and
not on the audience
so i want to highlight a passage that
you have in the book
which is um you know kind of reminiscent
of some statements i've made to others
on the podcast including
colleagues of yours across the way in
the physics department like cameron
vapha who's been on the show recently
we'll get to that
but uh but it's a statement attributed
to uh to this guy this finger puppet
this is carl sagan
and i had his wife uh his widow andrew
ian on the podcast
and i had his daughter on the podcast as
well but he's uh reputed to have saying
extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence and i've
never sat around in my laboratory
and said okay my grad students you know
my pulse
let's wait that's evidence but let's
wait for the extraordinary evidence what
do you make of that saying and how
flippant our colleagues are often to
dismiss things
maybe there's you know a chance they're
wrong and and or a chance they're right
but you know to dismiss it as well this
is
so much bigger or more important and who
by the way gets to say
what counts as you know extraordinary
except
for those that want to make a judgment
call so what do you make about that
often used trope that
extraordinary claims require we go into
the special file cabinet marked
extraordinary evidence
well as you said i think extraordinary
is a label that is very subjective
because even if you talk about dark
matter you know
weakly interacting massive particles
might be extraordinary
to one person and quite natural to
another person
so we should look for evidence let's put
it this way we should be guided by
evidence and we should not dismiss
evidence
that has anomalies just because it's not
extraordinary
because if you wanted you know to
believe only things that have
extremely high resolution and you would
never
converge in in in science you know look
at the evidence that was found in in
favor of einstein's theory of general
relativity
by eddington right it was very marginal
for the deflection of light by the sun
and in fact one of the experiments did
not support einstein and
nevertheless edicton fudged it and
argued that there is support and
you know then general relativity was
accepted now would you argue
well that was an extraordinary claim and
therefore we shouldn't believe eddington
no uh it turned out that generativity
was correct so
i would say let's just be guided by
evidence
not talk about extraordinary and
whenever there is something anomalous
that we cannot explain naturally
we should discuss possible explanations
or
if you look at the opposite situation
where
very commonly the scientific community
converges behind
an accepted notion for example that
the dark matter most of the matter in
the universe
which we don't know the nature of maybe
weekly interacting massive particles
that was the dominant view
for decades hundreds of millions of
dollars were invested in experiments
trying to find that particle
without success right now there are only
upper limits constraints but nobody
blames
those experimentalists for wasting
hundreds of millions of dollars in
trying to
rule out suggestions uh because that's
part of the scientific learning
experience you know you sometimes go in
directions that turn out
not to lead anywhere uh and so
the point is that even if the scientific
community believes that something is
natural and not extraordinarily
speculative
it turns out to be wrong so i think that
we should remove the word extraordinary
from the equation
and just look at evidence you find
mainstream people that worked for
decades now these are people working on
string theory
extra dimensions the multiverse super
symmetry
ideas that are mainstream for which
awards were given
for which people got their ego boosted
for which
people feel very proud of themselves and
discuss it
at length even though there is no
experimental evidence
so why doesn't that
you know why does that attract
the attention of the mainstream even
though it's extraordinary having an
extra dimension is really extraordinary
there is no evidence for it nevertheless
communities of thousands of physicists
work on it so to argue
that the search for extraterrestrial
technologies
is speculative and therefore it
shouldn't be discussed there should be a
taboo about discussing it
whereas to discuss extra dimension is
completely legitimate
that to me is the distortion of the
spirit of science because
we know that we exist there is evidence
for that and therefore
we should look for others out there and
how dare the scientists
not work on a subject that is of so much
interest to the public
when the public funds science so there
is
you know in this equation there is a lot
of arrogance of the scientific community
saying
we don't want to deal with a question
that the public cares about
even though we have the technology to
address it
we want to do intellectual gymnastics
demonstrating to each other that we are
smart
working in extra dimensions working on
anti-deceiter space
in which we can solve some complicated
equations for which
you know there is no connection to
reality between that
and the space that we live in which is
the sitter not
anti the sitter we give each other
awards for working on anti the sitter
space
and we are extremely proud of the
accomplishments that we
reach mathematically in that space
give you know accolades and say how
great the
situation is because a thousand people
are working on this
instead of connecting it to the real
world instead of connecting it
to the real people you know who cares
what anti-deceit space properties are
in the general public nobody and
why is this part of the mainstream
when the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence is not to me
the current scientific culture has a big
problem
it's geared towards
improving your self-image towards
building
an echo chamber around you that would
make your
voice louder and maintain a bigger image
of yourself so that you can get awards
get into
important societies and
get appreciate get more likes on twitter
but that's completely orthogonal to the
actual purpose of science which is
a dialogue with nature having
experiments educate us
correct our notions you know quantum
mechanics would never be
thought of if there were no experiments
in fact einstein resisted quantum
mechanics the standard
you know he had a problem with that but
we would never think about quantum
mechanics without the experimental
feedback
so experiments help us improve our
imagination
and just tossing it aside and saying i
don't need experiments
you know i can think about anti-disease
space and come up with the unification
of quantum mechanics and gravity
to me first it's arrogant second it's
the wrong approach we're heading the
wrong
you know we took the wrong turn in the
highway
and you know that's a strategic decision
because you're guiding
herds of young scientists in directions
that do not lead anywhere
so um you and i are lost together in
2014
uh cruising down some highway in moscow
going to a conference commemorating
the 100th birthday of jaco
zeldovich who was sort of a grand
advisor of mine
and you know we're going down the
highway and it was just a few months
after the bicep two affair
that i described uh in my book losing
the nobel prize
uh and and uh before we get to the topic
of you know this this sort of
you know way that the public perceives
science the way that there's sort of
this
you know military industrial complex or
i call it the media industrial complex
where
you everything has to be this huge
discovery because we're all terrified
that the public's going to realize that
you know basically we would do what we
do for free i mean
you talk about your childhood in such uh
you know in such
very simple terms but very lovingly
tenderly describing what it was like to
grow up in
in israel as you did a very simple way
of life
and almost pleasant almost longingly uh
melancholy for that simple time and now
we live in like everything has to be
this huge smash hit that could someday
garner a nobel prize i was told by my
uh chair at the time whose father was
demetri bassoff uh dimitri basso his
father was nikolai bassoff who won the
nobel prize for
co-invention of the laser he was like we
hired you because we thought you had a
good chance of winning the nobel prize
and you know and how about that we came
very close and of course
we'll get into that but i do want to
take one step back i do think that
theorists in general um have sort of
a an advantage a built-in asymmetry in
that it's easy to create theories it's
very hard to test theories
so you and i are both jewish and we both
know the famous
catechism of judaism is the shema which
is basically
uh means hear oh israel but we won't get
into theology very much unless you want
to
but but there's a line in there and it
says do not follow after your
eyes or after your heart after which you
stray
and actually in hebrew you can correct
me if i'm wrong but it really means like
prostitute yourself that
people will basically subjugate their
morality their their their love of their
spouse
for money or for power or for whatever
and i think that's
sort of a sign that the bible is warning
us about confirmation bias
and that we tend to fall in love with
our ideas and feel that
that science is a zero-sum game that if
string theory
if uh if there are extraterrestrials if
umura is extraterrestrial
then it's going to take away attention
dollars research funding
from uh five-dimensional ads cft
um now my other friends are your friends
elisa randall
who's been on the show and and of course
they'll say no no this is not just
interesting math
um we actually make predictions and i
asked him well i didn't know that string
theory made testable predictions that we
can confront with experiment
and he said yes the string theory has
predicted that the mass of the electron
has to be
somewhere between 10 to the minus 23 you
know planck masses and 10 to the minus
one planck masses
i said okay you know there you go and
and i said well should the string theory
predict that my weight is below you know
10 to the 13 kilograms i mean that's
that's
true i mean the question should be
reversed
can they put some skin in the game can
they say
make a prediction that can be proven
wrong and
you know that's an interesting question
because qumran vapha himself gave a
colloquium
in which he said you know string the
string theory landscape implies
something about cosmic inflation
and i wrote to him afterwards i said
great so if we
from the microwave background an
isotropic discover that
inflation occurred differently than the
kind of description you gave
would that rule out string theory he
said no
it would rule out the connection that i
drew between string theory
and for a particular moment right theory
will always be right and i said
okay well then it's not a prediction how
can it how can you
say that something is a prediction if
you can't rule it out so you see
that the point is they are not putting
skin in the game and
it reminds me of theology but all
let me give you an example where
theology actually three examples where
theology can be
can put some skin in the game okay one
example
my book inspired a student in the
english department
to pursue a phd related to the search
for
extraterrestrial life just a few months
ago and she invited me to the thesis
exam
and in the series exam one of the
professors asked her
do you know why giordano bruno
was burnt on the stake and she said well
you know he was an obnoxious person
uh people didn't like him which is true
it is yeah
but the professor said no actually it's
because
he argued that other stars are like the
sun
and they could have a planet around them
like the earth
which could potentially host life
and the church found it offensive
because if that life
sinned then christ should have
visited those other planets and you need
multiple
duplicates of christ which is
unacceptable and so they burned the guy
so i said great i said to this professor
great so you are offering now an
experimental test of this theology
because
suppose we find intelligent life on a
planet
we visit that place we see that these
creatures sin and we ask them did you
witness
christ and if they say no then we
rule out experimentally that theology
so that's an example for ruling out a
theology
and that's an expensive experiment it's
an expensive example
you know martin buber is quoted by elie
wiesel
as saying you know the christians
argue that the messiah arrived
and will come back again the jews say
that the messiah will only arrive in the
future
he said why argue both sides
agree that the messiah will arrive in
the future
when the messiah arrives we can ask him
or her were you here before
and resolve the conflict it's a very
simple experimental test
of one theology or the other a third
example
abraham you know when he
uh heard the voice that told him
to sacrifice his son you know that's a
story from the bible yeah
right so suppose
abraham had an a cell phone with
a voice memo on it up you know
if you had that up he would just press
the button and record the voice right
and
make everyone on earth a believer
unfortunately
these apps were not available at the
time of abraham
but it's another test of theology but i
think
yeah even for theology you have tests so
if string theory cannot come up with
such a test
cannot put some skin in the game then
what are we talking about
i think i think we're talking about uh
you know kind of this dominant
paradigm and just like i think that
people have
you know i i am a practicing jew i call
myself a devout agnostic
because like freeman dyson who plays a
big role in the book as well
uh freeman regarded the question of
god's existence as
uh as definitely a puzzle but perhaps a
mystery in other words
maybe it could be solved like a rubik's
cube and i and i told this to come run
because his book is called puzzles to
unravel
the universe and i said you know cameron
do you ever play with a rubik's cube and
he said sure and i said yeah i always
get
i can get five sides of the rubik's cube
all the right cut but i never get that
six
can you help me out and he didn't get it
he didn't get it but anyway he's a
wonderful person i i really enjoyed
talking to him
and that he did go on the record and but
but the fact is he felt this need to
to really subsume this but getting back
to the proving of god i just want to
take a side note
even the the thing that i like about so
i was a roman catholic
altar boy in the catholic church that i
described in my book i was an atheist
now i'm a practicing practicing agnostic
but but the point is
i've had a lot of exposure to different
religions and i found
in my book i actually had it as a test
as well because the the
as you know the fifth commandment is so
honor thy mother and thy father it's
very important it's the first religion
that
put women on equal status in that level
that you couldn't just honor your father
you had to honor your mother as well so
i said about
kind of this quest in my book uh
basically if you could if you could
prove that inflation
uh took place that might lead
credence to to the inflationary
narrative but that might you know that
might be rejected by people right
you might say well some like paul
steinhardt our mutual colleague and
friend
he might say well inflation predicts an
infinite number of different
so even if you did provide evidence
scientists might not accept it
and so too i said well one thing i could
do is honor my mother and my father
and see unique among all ten
commandments there's actually a reward
promised for kiva do you know you
remember what it is
no what is it so the reward is that your
days on earth your days
will be lengthened so it's it's the only
mitzvah that
promises a reward besides uh chewing
away the mother bird from her nest we
won't get into that but there's two
commandments
so i said it's pretty interesting it
could be falsified you could falsify the
torah
if you honor your mother and father and
then you die at a young age
we're not going to get into that but my
question is looking at
evidence scientists will dismiss things
you know as arthur c clarke the namesake
of this podcast in the center i
co-direct
he said for every expert there's an
equal and opposite expert you know that
your colleagues will say
uh avi you know you're just you just got
you should stick to your lane
you know you're an eminent cosmologist
just stick to that why do you get into
extra terrestrial we haven't even spoken
about it so let's get there i want to
talk about the book
um why don't you just stick to your lane
why do you care about some
piece of schmutz floating through the
galaxy well actually
my lane is now the search for life
because i have an 870 page
textbook coming out in june by harvard
university press with my
former postdoc manasville lingam that
describes uh how the search for both
primitive
and intelligent life should be conducted
scientifically so
here is a lane it's actually a highway
and it's the wave of the future you know
i think that would become one of the
major frontiers you know my experience
from the past
i worked in areas that were not really
shared by many
colleagues and then they become they
became mainstream examples include
the study of the first stars the first
galaxies on which i have a textbook
uh gravitational wave astrophysics uh
imaging black holes
you know all of these i worked on when
the community was very small
of people interested in and then they
became fads and
i don't really pay attention to the
response that people
now with respect to objects like umuah
that we will talk about
my point is simple i want to ask to
monitor the sky for example with the
vera rubin observatory
that will come online within three years
and look for objects that are
as peculiar as this one and basically
um once we find one heading our way send
a
cubesat that will take a close-up
photograph of it
so there will be no doubt that it's
unusual
i don't want us to suffer from lack of
evidence i want to collect as much
evidence as possible and we can do it
with existing technology
but if you ahead of time have a
prejudice if you say that when you go to
the beach
and look at the at the beach all the
time you will see just
seashells that were naturally produced
and you will never see anything else
then obviously you will never find a
plastic bottle i mean if you walk down
the beach sometimes you find a plastic
bottle that is not officially made
and my point is that by examining all
the objects that enter into the solar
system
we might find a message in a bottle so
it's a different way
of studying or searching for
extraterrestrial technologies different
from looking for a radio signal
and why shouldn't we do that you know
all the people that try to explain
omuamua
by natural processes had to invent
something that we have never seen before
like a dust bunny you know there was
there were several papers on that a dust
bunny pushed by sunlight
or a hydrogen iceberg you know things
that we've never seen before
so i say okay if it's something that we
have never seen before
why not consider a technological origin
you know like
what is the problem in discussing it as
a possibility just like weakly
interacting massive particles
are one possibility for the dark matter
axions are another
we collect evidence try to figure out
what's the problem there is nothing bad
about it it's
part of science and the public is
interested
how dare the scientists shy away from it
avi do you remember uh you certainly do
probably in the 80s
and the so-called valentine's day event
that
blas cabrera and colleagues at stanford
university claim to detect
the magnetic monopole that existed in
the universe
um as i was reading your book uh i felt
you don't go far enough
because uh i know if i had access to an
eccentric russian billionaire
instead of uh just a uh a local a local
new york billionaire
uh who funds uh most of my research uh
i would say to him look yuri it's great
to send uh you know
tens of thousands of small spacecraft as
you are doing with
the star shot and the star and the and
the star uh chips
but um this thing might be the only one
and it might be the only one i get to in
my lifetime in your lifetime
umua so first let me ask you avi um
if you had his billions uh you know or
or you know
we're gonna get to bitcoin later uh but
but uh but if you had his billions
or you could even convince him why not
just go after that's the only thing that
you know
are you willing to bet you know your
stake your
scientific reputation and say let's not
go to proxima century
b that might be nice but this thing is
definitely
signature no other i mean not no other
you wouldn't say that you say 91 percent
something like that
why not go there why not go farther
explain what's so weird about it
its shape a lot of things look like you
know and i think there was a disservice
as always happens in your field in this
field i'm going to call it your field
now
that you're writing the definitive
textbook soon to be definitive textbook
but um but now it's in your field so
your field suffers from you know the
the sagas adam frank calls it prosthetic
far heads
you know like aliens and star trek but
now you know
or you believe you know this object is
likely to have come
from a technologically advanced
civilization why not go after it chase
it down
and not wait for another one to happen
to come by when vera rubin's online
maybe this is the valentine's day event
for extraterrestrial intelligence just a
quick
interruption in this fascinating
conversation with the incomparable avi
loeb of harvard university
and as they ask you to please do me the
very small
favor astronomically speaking of course
of leaving a small constellation
an asterism as we astronomers call it of
stars in a rating for the
into the impossible podcast on itunes or
wherever you're watching or listening to
this podcast please subscribe and share
it
with your friends that's really the only
way that i get uh more and more
guests like today's guest avi loeb i
also ask you to
uh to subscribe to my newsletter where
i'm gonna send out uh continuing
in a series of free ebooks that i send
out to my subscribers and these involve
theories of everything
the great debate and astronomy we're
going to have a separate one about alien
technology
and also get a sneak peek into my new
book coming out hopefully later on this
year
so i hope you'll do that go to
briankeating.com sign up for my mailing
list i only
send out one per week and it will really
eliminate for you
the hottest topics in science and in
ways that you can not only
learn more and get resources from the
community you can win giveaways signed
books meteorites
and so forth but you can also get uh
with resources to
educate people in your life as well
whether it be children or
friends etc so anyway please leave a
rating
stars are more the better but even one
star
and a critical review will be helpful to
me i read each and every one of them
and then yes please do subscribe to my
newsletter brianketing.com now
back to today's episode with the
really unparalleled avi loeb i hope
you're enjoying
this uh conversation of of someone who's
really
completely unafraid unashamed and will
speak his mind whenever he darn well
chooses so i had a great time in this
podcast i hope you enjoy the rest of it
signing off until the very end of the
episode brian keating
well the problem with chasing it first
of all we detected it only when it was
receding away from us
faster than any rocket can chase it uh
it's just like seeing a guest for dinner
and then realizing the guest is strange
by the time
he or she lives through the front door
into the dark street
i'm sorry i'm sorry i did that when i
came over for pesach dinner i'm so sorry
so um the the thing is that we want to
catch it when it's approaching us and
we discovered it in october 2017
if we were to discover it in july when
it was approaching earth we could have
sent the cubesat with a camera that
would take a photograph
i was actually visiting the mount
haleakala in maui
in hawaii because we were on vacation
with
my family and i gave a seminar at the
observatory and
uh my if we were if we knew about the
object back then then i would
advocate taking a photograph but we
didn't know and
so we cannot really chase it for another
reason
right now even if we had a fast
spacecraft
and that is because it dims it gets
fainter
as inversely with the distance to the
fourth power
because the fraction of light
intercepting it falls off as
one over distance squared and then
another factor of one of a distance
squared for us to see the flux
the reflected flux so all together it's
now
a million times fainter than it was when
it was near us
and then you need a big telescope on
board
of a spacecraft to find exactly where it
is
and that is not practical so i think we
should aim to
look for other objects that are peculiar
now there was another interstellar
visitor
since then uh called borisov
and it's called after a russian amateur
astronomer
gennady borisov that found it and it
looked just like a comet
it had a cometary tale unlike umuah that
didn't have a cometary theme
so people came to me and said oh look
borisov looks
just like a comet that we have seen
before doesn't it convince you
that o muammua is natural and i said
look
when i went on the first date with my
wife
she looked special to me and the fact
that i met a lot of women
afterwards didn't change my opinion
about her so why should i
change my opinion about what just
because we saw a comet
right and so the point is that we should
be
exploring other objects that
are weird uh and
find them before they pass us and
try to now there was another peculiar
object i should mention
found in september 2020 just a few
months ago
and that object was given the name
2020so
by the minor planet center you know an
astronomical organization that gives
names to objects and harvests right
harvard runs it yes exactly
and they give it that gave it the name
of 2020 so
and then astronomers noticed that it
moves in an orbit that it is not very
different from the orbit of the earth so
it's bound to the sun
and they went back in time to see where
it came from and found that it
actually came from the earth in 1966
and then they looked at the history
books and realized oh yeah there was
this lunar surveyor
uh mission to lunar lander
that they failed but there was a rocket
booster that was kicked into space
and that is probably the rocket booster
now
that object before it was recognized
that it's that the rocket booster
it uh the the astronomers figure that in
fact it has
an extra push uh because of the
reflection of sunlight
so it's not just the force of gravity
that dictates its orbit
but there is an extra push which is
similar to
and so my point is this is a hollow
object very thin
it had exhaust there was a an extra push
from
reflection of sunlight that we could
recognize and we can tell the difference
between that
and a rock we can tell that it's
artificial and
in this case we know that it was made by
us but in the case of
doesn't look like a rock and was
potentially made by another civilization
when you think about the civilization
that might have created it
do you think that they targeted the
earth because i think that would
that would alter my priors right if you
were if you were trying to send
something
to you know proxima century b i mean you
make the case
how large a technical challenge it is
and i don't think you can just say
uh you know well their technology is so
much more advanced if they can create
something that can travel these vast
distances
uh but i think you know it changes the
way i would think about it
and and i wonder how you think about it
if it was targeting the earth
do you think that there's reason to
suspect because you don't really come
down one way or another in the book but
i don't i don't think it was targeting
the earth
and the reason is simple i think that we
are common
you know if you open the morning
newspaper you realize we are not very
smart we're not very
you know we're making a lot of mistakes
all the time speak for yourself avi
speak for yourself
no my point is also you know if imagine
us coming from the soup of chemicals
that were
on earth early on and you look at recipe
books
you know you can start from the same
ingredients and get very different cakes
right
and what's the chance that this soup of
chemicals
made the best cake that you can imagine
it's it's probably very small
and you know if you cook the same
chemicals on other planets
slightly differently you might get much
better cake so i would argue that we are
you know sort of an average kind of
outcome
and that there are much smarter beings
out there
and you know when you walk on on the
sidewalk
and there are ants under your feet you
don't pay attention to every ant it's
not very significant
so i don't think we deserve let's put it
this way we don't deserve the attention
i don't think they would spy on us
because
you know we are so common and so in
uninteresting and so foolish if you look
at human history
that we would not attract a lot of
attention um
so i would assume that uh
you know we are not uh worthy
of the earth and also if there is a very
advanced civilization that let's say
is a billion years old that
technological you know they
probably created a cocoon a habitat
where they have everything they need and
they would close themselves off
just i call it social distancing on a
cosmic scale
you know if you have everything you need
you don't want invaders you don't want
you want to reduce the risk you close
yourself
you don't look after others and
you know in that case you might say oh
we will never find about them
but that's not true because they have to
throw their trash you know they produce
some trash
and we can be just like those
investigative journalists
that they search the trash of
celebrities in hollywood to find out
about their private lives
you know we can find that trash
another thing you talk about a lot in
the book is uh
is being humble obviously that's a
that's a that's a biblical virtue as
well
um i wonder though you know what would
it really mean
and and i can't resist because you know
i know you are a scholar of many things
not just
science but also you think deeply about
philosophy and in fact you wanted to be
a philosopher
as i learned from the book and maybe
theology isn't so far off i
look at the case of the and i mention
this in my book as well
i wrote a book about the the detrimental
effects that the nobel prize has on
science
scientists and the public's perception
of science that we elevate
people uh to the status of gods we
know their names to the extent that we
know any scientist names it's stephen
hawking neil degrasse tyson
bill nye and uh you know probably avi
loeb but but that's about it right so
um and then the kid sees that says i'm
not avi loeb i'm not einstein and you
know
i said that to jim gates who wrote a
book about about einstein
and he's like einstein wasn't einstein
in the beginning and and here's someone
i look up to like that now
um in the case of the nobel prize people
aspire to it and
it makes funding decisions it makes
decisions for entire fields for
departments as i already mentioned
and so i wrote this book i saw the the
the uh the impact that it has on my
field of astronomy and physics in
general
and it was pretty negative and then i
saw duncan haldane came to ucsd to give
a colloquium because he was a professor
here when he did the work that later
garnered him
the nobel prize in in 2016
uh for the prediction of topological uh
matter with strange properties he
brought his actual nobel prize he left
it with me
this is this is some gelt from hanukkah
left over but uh
but uh but he brought it and and
everybody was there and everybody wanted
to like they didn't care about him they
wanted to touch the nobel prize they
want to feel the nobel prize they took
selfies
i took a selfie with it avi i i come
down like i hate the nobel prize
no i took a selfie and i realized you
know we're not so different
from the israelites who after they
supposedly witnessed the splitting of
the sea
and and and and god's miracles tenfold
over
destroying their enemy and liberating
them in redemption
they worship a golden calf 40 days later
right so
how far are we from this in other words
how how much do you think that people
would really
change how they live their daily life if
they discovered
i mean we already know and you i think
you talk about this in the book
if you look at a chimpanzee and you
assay their dna
it's about 99 point something you know
percent identical to human beings
if but nobody watches and says you know
i'm just like an ape
you know i'm a hairless ape uh i should
have some humility why do you expect it
would be different
if we discover moomoo is alien
technology
well two things i wanted to mention
first of all i
completely agree with you that science
should be driven by curiosity it's about
the dialogue with nature
getting an answer from nature you know
through experiments
and that will educate us improve our
imagination
uh nobody would have thought of quantum
mechanics out of the blue
and uh the second is
that being an astronomer teaches you
modesty because you realize that
you know there are 10 to the 20 planets
like the earth in the observable volume
of the universe
even if you conquer a big piece of land
on earth like emperors or kings did
you know it's just like an ant uh you
know wrapping its
legs around the single grain of sand on
the landscape of a huge beach it's not
very impressive
there is no way for us to be impressive
even if we demonstrate our superiority
relative to another person you know
that's ridiculous
this ambition of showing off getting
awards
like what what are we talking about are
these really awards
i mean that's nothing compared to
understanding
reality figuring out what the universe
is it's not about
us doing science is about
nature you know trying to figure out
nature let's do that
let's focus on the real thing rather
than focus on ourselves because if we
focus on ourself
then we do intellectual gymnastics you
know if you go to the olympics
what do you see you see people running a
hundred meters is there any significance
to the length the distance of 100 meters
no we could have defined it to be 50
meters you could have find it to be 20.
just like the anti-disease space you
know it's something that we decide about
and then we test the ability of people
to do it the best
you know and it bears no cosmic
significance it's about us
testing us so you can of course give
jobs to people based on how well they do
under these defined circumstances
but it says nothing about nature if you
want to understand nature you need to go
out collect data about nature and figure
out
whether your ideas are right or wrong
you need to put some
skin in the game you need to allow
yourself to be wrong
if you don't allow like uh for example
alan good
speaking about inflation you know like
so i asked him
at the public discussion i said is
inflation
falsifiable can you prove inflation
wrong
based on an experimental fact
and he said it's a silly question
i said what do you mean it's a silly
question any phys theory in physics is
supposed to be
testable right and he said well
it will all be it's just like a part it
will always be right irrespective of
what the experiment is
i can design find a model that would
accommodate it
so i have a problem with that because
then you're not learning anything new if
you can tailor your theory to fit any
fact
then it's not really you're not really
learning anything
because anything so anyway um
but um coming back to your your point
you know let me let me make my um you
know so
so the universe tells us that we should
be modest
okay and we should accept that and not
value prizes so much
um i think the biggest thing for us to
think about
is something that you can find in the
bible which is
the story of knox arc you know noah
was worried about the great flood
destroying life
on earth and so he decided to build an
ark
and the dimensions of the ark are
specified by the way they are very
similar to the dimensions of a mummy
yeah
he wanted to put animals on the ark like
that so that life would be preserved
during the great flood that's the story
line
yeah we should think along the same
lines because currently all our eggs are
in one basket here on earth
and if some catastrophe happens like for
example we don't
take good care of our climate or an
asteroid impacts us or
you know in a billion years the sun the
sun will boil off all the oceans on
earth uh
then we will lose everything that is
precious to us
and how do we build the nox arc that
will prese
you know if you look at the printing
press that was invented by gutenberg
the big innovation was previously there
were
very few copies of the bible and
therefore each of them was extremely
precious because it was handwritten
but once the printing press came along
lots of copies were produced
and then if one of them gets damaged no
worries
so the same you know if we were to
establish copies
of life on earth elsewhere then we would
face
less risk if something bad happens here
and how do can we do that
we don't need to build a huge spacecraft
that can accommodate elephants
whales birds and so forth all we need to
do
is take a cubesat that has a very
advanced computer system
in it put a 3d printer
and learn how to produce synthetic life
with the 3d printer out of the raw
materials
that it finds on another planet so we
just need to fit the computer with
uh the information about the dna of
those animals that we want to reproduce
it goes there uses the raw materials and
makes
life the way we want it and once we make
those
just like the printing press once we
make copies then we would be less
worried about what happens here
yeah hopefully that's the biggest thing
for us as a civilization to think about
yeah i mean hopefully though you know
when i plant the
tomatoes in my garden i don't i throw
away the seed package i hope i hope
there'll be some use for the
originators of the dna and that that
create this uh interstellar noah's ark
um
i do want to touch this on one thing you
said before we kind of wind down with
some of the standard questions i ask all
my guests who
honor me with their presence as you are
today and uh that's that's
with regard again to this confirmation
bias that scientists seem to have but
don't
admit that they have and my theory is
that scientists are
even if they're atheist and 90 of the
national academy or national academy
member
they are either non-believers in god or
they
don't actively profess any sort of
religion maybe they don't deny it but
the number of agnostics is very small as
well anyway something like 90
don't actively affirm the existence of
god and yet
uh you hear statements from people like
guth like linday uh like other people
uh and lawrence krauss max tegmark who's
been on the show
and they'll say all sorts of things that
you know if the multiverse is true
and we have no reason according to so
the syllogism
is you know uh linday says that it's
almost impossible not to have
the multiverse if you have inflation
guth you just told me basically says
it's impossible to avoid inflation
therefore there is a multiverse uh
according to most people and then lenny
suskin has been on the show also thinks
because string theory provides evidence
uh in some sense for the existence of a
spectrum of different
habitable or it but they should they
should put some skin in the game they
should say
if this is found experimentally if you
go
with the samus observatory and you find
something okay can you rule out
any of their models no you know like no
i've had this conversation
i mean how can they argue that they make
predictions or that this is a scientific
you know this is not part of our
scientific well here's here's a counter
argument i talked to martin reece
uh this past monday and he said um uh
you know imagine that you were
uh trying to prove that the um that the
uh the
the earth is the center of the universe
so you take michelson morally
and you look at the michelson-morley
effect and that shows you
that the earth is stationary with
respect to the ether wind okay so
that was his exam my example is no but
that's one experiment
we have a lot of other so you might be
misled by one experiment and there are
many examples for that
where one experiment gave the wrong
impression and then there were other
experiments that
falsified the interpretation of that
experiment fine so we can be wrong along
the way
that is legitimate i mean you can have a
worldview that is completely distorted
that is supported by one experiment
okay but then you continue to test it
it continues to put some skin in the
game and you check it again and again so
that's that's
that's why i feel like i mean again not
with all respect
and covered to you i have to say that
i don't feel like you really believe
that umura is real because
if i knew that what you just said you
said two things today you said that
it wasn't targeted at us that means it
was random by definition it wasn't
intentionally sent to us in likelihood
that means that the chance of it
happening again could be extremely small
i mean it's not vanishing
but at least if i know there's if i know
there's a string theory habitable
universe
and it's in the constellation aquila and
i can look there
and i'll see it it'll be hard it'll cost
me a lot of money i would do anything to
see that so
okay why don't we go after and chase it
with a star chip
no no my point is if it was not
targeting us the conclusion is different
the conclusion is that there is a
population of objects
because we with pan stars we surveyed
the sky for a certain
duration a certain length of time or
let's say a few years let's say
and a certain volume that we were
sensitive to
in terms of objects of this size
reflecting sunlight
from that if you assume that it's a
member of a population
of random objects that we don't live at
a special time when panzers was
able to detect just the one object that
is in our entire neighborhood
uh if you assume the copernican
principle which says
you know things are sort of the typical
uh
you know that are typical at the time
that you observe them then it means
there are many
more okay and it means that lsst on the
vera rubin observatory will find once
per month such an object because it's
much more sensitive so actually i draw
the opposite conclusion
in the sense that it's a very testable
hypothesis
in the sense that there should be many
of those if it was not targeting us
if it was targeting us there may be very
few indeed
yeah because then it came on purpose but
then you ask yourself what's the chance
that we happen to live at a time when
one
such object comes close but just to
violate the copernican principle again
in terms of time anyway so
um all together i think the conclusion
is let's collect more evidence
and i wouldn't say that i no i i
actually
do think that you know we should base
our assertions on
evidence rather than prejudice and the
only way um
to avoid it is by us saying we know the
answer in advance
well yeah i mean i remember hearing it
um you know when it first came out and
you
first started to alert the the world to
this possibility that was
startling i mean you you know that it is
and uh it's it's an audacious claim
and i remember you saying things like we
have to gather more evidence and i was
like
well how are you going to do that if
it's lsst we can monitor this guy
but sorry avi just to just put one pin
on that i mean
if you got a letter from some force god
i'll call it god
so this is the only one what would you
do in other words that's the ultimate
skin in the game in my opinion is
you believe in it so much your skin is
fully on the skin of this of this object
no no but that violates okay that
violates the copernican principle so i
believe in the copernican prison
yeah the copernican principle has two
aspects to it one
that we don't leave at a special time
okay so even if these objects are rare
you know
still there is a certain frequency by
which such objects pass near earth
because it's very unlikely that if they
pass once per million years or once per
billion years that we would live
exactly at the time you know you would
look at the sky with past us
exactly at the time when it comes close
to earth that's very unlikely
and therefore i don't accept that notion
that we will never see any anything else
like it
in the future would you give up yeah
would you give a limit like when would
you
when would you give at some point you
might say i believe this one is
uh extraterrestrial we haven't seen any
in excellent number of years
let's go after a moment but what would
that be in other words when would you
say that your hypothesis what would it
take to falsify your hypothesis avi so
when lsst
looks at the sky in three years after
a year or two of not finding anything
like
then i would say maybe it's special
but before that i would not say that
now you also brought up the issue of god
and the science and
i wanted to mention the fact that you
know einstein accepted
the concept of god advocated by spinoza
because
spinoza associates god with nature
and you know uh to me the most
startling fact about the universe is the
laws of physics that we
uncover by experiments here on earth
appear to apply
all the way to the edge of the universe
you know the cosmic micro background and
so forth
and that's remarkable you know because
you know when you establish laws
in society you see lots of people
violating them but how come the universe
as a whole
is so organized and you know that order
to me
is fascinating yeah i asked people like
uh sean carroll once
and i'll ask you i can't resist i said
what do you think the odds of
the multiverse being true are
so what do you what do you say i say i'm
i don't want to discuss this question
because i cannot test it okay
you know we can waste our life just
talking about things like how many
angels can sit on a pin
and people did waste their life doing
that uh
you know we have a limited time here on
earth why not ask questions that we can
answer
right and then i asked him just for
completeness i asked him what do you
think he said about 50
odds that the multiverse is true uh and
uh and then he said uh and i said well
what are your odds uh estimation for the
existence of god and he said
less than one percent so i found that
interesting but the point is
anyone can say anything yeah exactly
there's nothing right it's it's
there is a lot of noise in the system if
you just have no evidence to support any
of these statements and
my point is let's reduce the noise let's
just talk about signal right
so the signal comes from nature itself
let's look at the evidence and try to
understand what it means
otherwise we can sit here forever and
talk about possibilities that are not
realized
right like antidepressant space for
example exactly
talk to your neighbors across harvard
harvard yard there about that
um before we turn to the final questions
i just you know
again cannot resist the the temptation
to discuss almost anything with you
but uh but yeah the notion of of kind of
publicity and science so recently
i was asked to comment on this discovery
of phosphine
in the clouds of venus and you know it
was a major press conference there were
leaks about it
it reminded me very much of bicep two
and actually i had on
sarah seeger on my podcast and uh she
talked about the
events of that discovery and follow-up
that's ongoing uh but i basically made
the case that you know
i i think press conferences turn science
into spectacles and i i don't really
feel like they have a great place in
science in fact
you know even like supposedly gold
standard of science is peer-reviewed
journals i mean those have only been
around for about a hundred years
it used to be a bunch of white guys got
together in the royal society
they did an experiment something blew up
or they cut open a frog
and that was it and then finally nature
came along but you know as they say
yeah just because it's published in
nature doesn't necessarily mean it's
wrong
um and we had things published and of
course we had everything what do you
make of that you were you were the
chair then and and you helped to set up
the press conference at harvard that we
announced it in front of
nobel laureates in the audience and to a
chorus of of both i found it interesting
because
on that same day there are people like
lawrence krauss saying
this proves there's no god uh because
there is a multiverse
and then there was people from the
discovery institute which is a christian
apologist
organization uh and they were saying
this proves there's a god because he's
fine-tuned the universe so anyway
what do you make of this relatively
recent phenomena which
was first invoked in my mind you know in
the 90s
well certainly in his 80s but then you
know most prominently when clinton
announced in the clinton
administration that we had found
evidence for martian meteorites in the
allen land hills meteorite of you know
so it's
extraterrestrial then there was
extremophile life
found in mono lake here in california
and other things anyway
it seems to have a lot to do with with
uh with press conferences and
extraterrestrial life i think i
i think it's a symptom of the way that
the system operates by which
the idea is not to expose anything to
the public
until the group of scientists that
collects the evidence is
confident that it can come out
the truth is you know that the king is
naked
right that in fact uh the process of
science is by
trial and error and there are many you
know times when we are mistaken
and so we should not elevate uh an
announcement uh to the level of
certainty
and then make a press conference we
should show how science works
and what i mean is if for example in the
context of
bicep if the group were to announce its
results and then other people would
criticize it and then there would be
some additional data coming in
let's say for planck and so forth and we
would sort it out that
that you know that's the process by
which science works and there is nothing
wrong about it
uh again one of the motivations was that
there could be a nobel prize attached to
such a discovery and you need to come up
you know in a public way in a
well-organized way so that others cannot
scoop you and you know so all of these
motivations
are unnatural to the process of science
and my point is that science is done by
iterations
we should not portray an image to the
public
where we never make mistakes you know
some scientists told me
you know that's really bad if something
it turns out to be wrong because then
the public will not believe when we tell
when we tell the public there is global
warming
uh they would not believe us because
here is you know an example where
scientists are wrong well
the truth is this king was naked for a
long time you know
the fact that you say the king is
dressed doesn't make it because if you
look at the history of physics there
were many instances where people made
statements that
turned out to be wrong including albert
einstein including
famous people and so the point is that
science
is all about you know a learning
experience we are trying to figure out
what nature is
and sometimes we make the wrong
inferences and the only way to correct
that is by getting more data
rather than closing ourselves in a room
figuring out something and then once
there is consensus in the room coming
out with a big announcement so that we
can get a big prize
you know that's not the natural way of
behaving i agree
with behaving is always making things as
tentative statements based on the data
we have that's the best conclusion we
can reach
and let others criticize it and you know
with um
that's exactly the approach i'm taking
you know i'm you know i was
in the military at a young age and uh
there was this saying that you know one
soldier
sometimes has to put the body on the
barbed wire so that others can go across
it in a battle
and as far as i'm concerned you know i'm
willing to put my body on the barbed
wire and get the
critics to attack me just so that
younger people in the future will will
benefit and be able to speak freely
great avi that's a really uh beautifully
expressed sentiment i just want to say
for your consideration you shouldn't
rule out using high-resolution microwave
background experiments to look for these
objects as well
simon's observatory one of our plans is
to look for planet nine and
transient phenomena and so don't don't
be so uh visual
spectrum centric as i know you have a
great deal of experience from the radio
down very low megahertz level college
radio stations
all the way up well avi i can't thank
you enough for
going into the impossible with me i want
to wish you all the best
of success wherever the book may take
you and
uh since you don't follow are not a big
presence on social media
i will uh do my best to promote you
inside and outside
of all these uh video venues and
otherwise i will let you know when this
comes out
anyway for now i wish you shabbat shalom
because you must not work
seven days a week that's the only thing
i would implore you not to do you're so
productive
you get so much done but we all need a
day of rest i make i command my
graduates the only thing i bring
religion into the public sphere i say
you i command you you may not work at
least one day a week i don't care what
day a week it is
you need to rest you need to recuperate
but i know you're going into a very busy
period for you i wish you stamina
i wish you resiliency but i know you
already have it so i wish you all the
best avi thank you for coming with us on
the show going into the impossible
thank you for having me it was a real
pleasure
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
you